[Music]  when you induce changes with exercise  where you induce changes with fasting  they're often the same changes  bdnf brain derived neurotrophic factor  is dramatically higher in rats that get  their exercise lower and those that  don't the ones that don't much more  vulnerable to alzheimer's  well bdnf it turns out the precursor to  that is beta-hydroxybutyric acid which  is the fatty acid your brain is  preferentially mobilizing during  water-only fasting bdnf goes up with  water fasting just like it does in  exercise  glycogen mobilizing enzymes go up and  exercise just like they do in fasting in  fact all of the biomarkers that we've  been able to look at that are improved  with exercise  improve with fasting exercise and  fasting are both  reversing the consequences of dietary  excess  i think that both of these processes  fasting and exercise share  a common biological benefit and that's  why we're seeing the biomarkers changing  with both that is crazy